hallo leute hinzu eure mal wandern
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender wie unboxing video und
heute packen wir den shopping queens
adventskalender aus den habe ich im
supermarkt gefunden und dachte mir so jo
ok da hat mich einfach kuku von der
grund warum ist ungeschminkt wird ist
weil da drin make-up dass ich jetzt
niemals mit doping in verbindung
gebracht hätte also sie machen sich am
ende halt fertig weiß es ja beim friseur
aber das geht so shopping make up
produkte drin sind passt jetzt für mich
erstmal nicht so zusammen aber das auch
meinen kanal noch nie ein richtiges im
make up tutorial gab können wir das
heute und ich schminke mich mit diesem
adventskalender
ich weiß auch gar nicht wann ich das
letzte mal ungeschminkt auf youtube zu
sehen war dunlop erstmal kommen jetzt
die haare weg weiß ich warum ich so rot
im gesicht bin gibt das gefühl immer
wenn ich mich für ein video vorbereite
werde ich nervös oder aufgeregt und dann
mach stimme das blut in mein gesicht
sieht man nur nicht mehr nicht sonst
trage das muss hier ganz so schön sein
hier ist meine herbert was ich immer zum
schminken auf 659 ich mache jetzt schon
mal ein bisschen von dave schon drauf
weil ich nicht glaube dass da drin
foundation drin sein wird und ich will
jetzt schon gleich anfang mit der
schminke reif wenn der foundation gleich
drin ist dann ach so ich kann das nicht
mit dem ju die videos also hier benutze
ich die bayarena
verbunden ist die ende habe ich im
sommer geholt da wir jetzt ein bisschen
aufgetragen damit auch mich nicht
aussehen wie scheiße und john mcclain
habe ich gelernt dass man immer so tut
ok und so hat es jetzt angemalt und
jetzt hat mir den adventskalender aus
und beginnen mit türchen nummer
hier haben wir ich denke zum auto
ich weiß nicht ob sie vielleicht an sie
den augenbrauen produkt da drin wir
lassen es erstmal türchen nummer eins
ist ein pinsel zum anwalt keitas überall
shopping queen drauf steht für so ein
shopping queen fan es ist glaube ich ein
gutes geschenk nummer zwei okay die
nummer zwei in pink anweist shadow bin
ich gespannt wie die prohaska fühlt sich
sehr weich analysen bestzeit das ist
eine farbe und ich muss sagen ich finde
sie richtig gut kann natürlich immer
eine lokale gleich mal auf bevor ich
stelle auftragen nutze ich immer meinen
die casey schätzt kaymer
der satz gehört es lange ok also machen
wir mal noch ein bisschen was vom hellen
drauf kriegen wir sind von facebook mit
allen shopping queen produkten diese
farbe finde ich echt gar nichts
geschätzt
so jetzt müssen wir mutig werden mit dem
road also der ist natürlich nicht so
toll pigmentiert was ich aber besser
finde weil seine farbe wenn die zustand
pigmentiert ist dann sieht es immer
schnell aus wie ich will dramatisches
make up machen aber ich kann es
irgendwie nicht und tief muss man halt
immer wieder bisschen mehr aufbauen aber
das ist ok in die farbe sehr sehr schön
ok ja absolut
zufrieden ich hätte es wirklich nicht
erwartet ich dachte das wird jetzt hier
so ein trash keine ahnung von queen
neuer geheimtipp türchen nummer drei
hier haben wir ein lippen kleiner pinsel
wir haben das nicht benutzen also ein
bisschen härter wahrscheinlich okay für
ihr nummer vier mütter sagen ich schaue
sehr gerne shoppen deswegen ist dieses
video so halb ironisch einheit nicht die
nummer vier ist sony bam applikator tat
mit so ein ding eigentlich kein budget
mehr auf benutze immer ein pinsel
deswegen brauche ich ihnen jetzt nicht
so unbedingt studieren immer höhen
was verbirgt sich hinter natürlich immer
fünf dem benutze ich sofort entdecken
wir jetzt hier den skandal und sind
haare in dem lippenstift nein er sie zu
papin aus und super toll riecht nach
erdbeere oder so gehaltvoll klar bin ich
total die schöne farbe sehr natürlich
und sehr sodass man kann ihn halt echte
jeden tag tragen
türchen nummer 6 nikolaus viacom wie
verschaffen für ihn schlüsselanhänger
ich finde so schlüsselanhänger braucht
man wirklich nicht mehr weil ich kaufe
mir ein schlüssel
menger d nicht so schön finden und dann
warten von räumlichkeit über nur
schlüssen
also wie viele schlüsselanhänger kann
man brauchen das türchen nummer kleiner
pinsel ich habe das gefühl so frauen
über 35 benutzen immer noch voll gerne
eyeliner pensel ich jetzt nicht mehr so
hammerl einer aber eher so rotter leyen
nein wir machen uns den sommer
ich mag diesen look nicht mehr an wir
können sie auch in die wasser die hier
einmal finde das sieht immer zu krass
aus malz in die wasserlinie wahlen warum
nicht haben wir den richtigen shopping
queen look also ich glaube er ist gut
hier gibt auf jeden fall sehr viel farbe
aber er läuft auch ja schalten eyeliner
ne also außer bei smokey eyes würde ich
den jetzt nicht benutzen kann ich auch
nicht gut auf tragen warum immer weiter
türchen nummer 8 ohm ein gott zum glück
wieder eine klassische höhe mal in folge
die leider nicht mal das training hat
das heißt sie kostet wohl wirklich
zweifel habe sie funktioniert sehr gut
man muss auch sagen ich habe jens
kalender 25 euro gekostet man darf
eigentlich nicht zu viel erwarten so
eine nagelfeile zu adoptieren immer 9
ich weiß nicht was man damit machen soll
also sind das sticker also ja aber wofür
sticker ja also sticker mit zehn ist
auch pinsel die haben halt alle diese
sind die karre was okay es würde ich
jetzt nicht für lidschatten benutzen
aber vielleicht sondern
concealer haben guten film konsum ein
concealer benutze ich immer den von
realtech niewerth aber auch nicht so
synthetisches h oder nicht so dieses
fand ich meine das ist super glatte haar
meist noch mal das türchen nummer
sie haben wir einen flush mit drei
farben drin die man dann natürlich
zusammen mit ist okay ich bin gespannt
sagt er
doch ich bin den schirm geht auf jeden
fall klar also der liegt dort dunkler
aus wenn man dann mit dem finger drauf
gibt hat man so er seine bruder version
davon sieht auch so ein bisschen mehr
aus als ob man sich pudern würde und
gleichzeitig halt ein bisschen farbe
dran geht was aber gar nicht in dieser
gegend hier so schlecht ist nicht so
eine starke farbe ist mein wie die
meisten leute mögen sich auch nicht so
stark zu schminken
deswegen ist das schon okay ziehen immer
jetzt gehen wie crazy eyeshadow schwarze
einstellung basis wieder mehr benutztes
der branche schon als ob das so für eine
große breite masse sein soll
aber das ist richtig schwarz schwarz und
das daneben ist so cool silber für eine
halloween ergab ist es perfekt aber
halloween das halt nur einmal im jahr
machen wir jetzt und smokie einer bei
daraus versuche mal was leute ich
versuche mal was
[Musik]
ja ich habe gerade wenn man nicht man
sich hier wirklich
aber ihr habt mir das wissen look den
wirten look ich weiß nicht wer wie
liebschaften für die produziert aber es
fällt mir nicht so viel auf wandel und
das ist bei der farbe schon echt gut er
gut leute das machen wir von smokie hier
das gut an make-up ist man kann sich
ausprobieren rumspielen versetzen
also ich muss sagen ist trifft schon den
shopping queen weit weil ich fühle mich
wie die mädels die dann immer beim
friseur allem was man kriegen regt es
überhaupt hatte dann noch jemand was
mache ich hier
ich weiß gar nicht wie lange gibt es
shopping queen schon ich weiß dass ich
es damals mit meiner schulfreunde in der
küche geschaut und ihre mutter ist auch
mal mit uns geschaut und das ist schon
15 jahre her gibt es shopping bin schon
solange ich wollte immer schon mal mit
[Musik]
mir zweite hälfte nummer 13
hier haben wir einen frauen ich benutze
privat ist eigentlich ich bin jetzt
eigentlich kein monster mehr weiß auch
ich habe ein bisschen vergessen machen
damit besser macht
das macht man so auf jeden fall nicht so
sehr extremes make up was ich hiermit
browser geht man also sehr sensibel und
konturiert man eigentlich mit bronze
oder welche irgendwann angefangen konnte
nur noch zum konkurrieren zu benutzen
aber eigentlich hat browns doch so sein
dass es aussieht als ob die haut so von
der sonne geküsst bot ja ist er jetzt
gut sieht schön aus also wie ich das
bewerten kann als nicht braun so
benutzer einfach meine hände
denn beim thema nachwuchs sehen die
nagellacke sind auf jeden fall mega süß
aus oh mein gott diese kleine krone
kommen ja hier ist super scheiß nägel
ihren bisher toni schön man muss ihn auf
jeden fall zwei mal auftragen das nicht
schlimm ist aber es ist eine sehr schöne
natürliche farbe die einfach jeder
tragen kann und das ist bei so einem
adventskalender echt wichtig wenn ich so
ein richtiger shopping queen fan wäre
und keine folge verpassen würde dann
würde ich mich so froh über so einen
kleinen fiesen shopping green nagellack
tun um 15.47 besser haben das ist das
hier ich habe halt gute pinsel deswegen
werde ich die pinsel wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut gebrauchen können kann ich
direkt alle wegschmeißen sportlich
verschenken aber rad zum tabletten von
als scheiß den ich hier auf dem gesicht
gehabt für diabetes gut an
hier nochmal richtig jeffrey star excuse
me ist dessen süße lipgloss ich sterbe
jetzt bin ich gespannt was es wirklich
guten lipgloss zu machen ist echt schwer
[Musik]
die haben einfach mega produkte gemacht
also jetzt nicht so mega oh mein gott
high end super class irgendwas aber das
ist einfach wichtig gute sachen heilig
lob jetzt einfach hier
20 minuten lang shopping wien 17
oh ja darauf bin ich so unendlich
gespannt nach skara eine gute mascara zu
finden ist schwer
einfach nur deswegen ich bin ja ist eine
gute mascara ich mag es einfach wenn die
wimpern so nach vorne einfach schön lang
und schwarz so er hat aussagen und nicht
so klumpig aufzwang voluminös gemacht
werden die mascara ist der hammer ich
bin einfach schockiert ich bin
schockiert nummer 18
zum glück haben sie mich nicht bezahlt
um diesen adventskalender zu testen weil
sonst würde es gerade und wirken wie die
übelste eklige probe überrascht dass die
produkte nicht scheiße sind das sind
meine plus ihn rückt ein minarett luxor
team gut so
probieren wir mal den roten lipgloss
[Musik]
da überrascht wie kann ich zu viel auf
oder was man hier lebt muss heute hat
nicht zuviel aufgetragen werden weil
sonst so diese es gibt definitiv bessere
für den preisen ist vollkommen in
ordnung wirklich vollkommen in ordnung
türchen nummer 19 da rein lidschatten in
brauntönen sehr dezent tolle transition
farbe da drin meinte ich hier gleich mit
meinem neuen applikator hier oben was
von der transition fördern
ich meine man benutzt den lidschatten ja
nicht alle für einen look deswegen ist
es auch übertrieben alles hier auch zu
tragen da war so komisch und krasses
make up in meinem gesicht zu sehen ich
habe mich so lange nicht voll geschminkt
türchen nummer 20 denkweisen roter
lippenstift ist wieder sehr natürlicher
faktor ist ein bisschen nah dran an dem
anderen aber immer noch anderes also ein
bisschen mehr rotanteil in der mischung
21 ist ein albtraum pencil ich male mir
meinen einbruchs immer mit anastacia
beverly hills an das ist auch das beste
würde ich jedem empfehlen
ich kann mich aber shopping queen hier
zurück zum stift motivieren schon
verklagt ich glaube ich hab's
übertrieben wir haben hier unseren
pencils habe ich mit dem stift
aufgetragen und verblendet ist mit dem
pinsel in meine augenbrauen hinein
ich bin echt ein bisschen schockiert
finde die produkte sind halt wirklich in
ordnung auch wenn ich ein bisschen viel
benutzt habe geht das klar
was meint ihr oder bin ich gerade
irgendwie habe ich einen schlaganfall
und mehreren dieses produkt furchtbar
aus jetzt überfordert nicht einfach wenn
der adventskalender gut ist die nummer
23 noch ein nagellack in der farbe rot
schön nummer 23 noch einlage leute das
ist aber hier nur schöne farbkombination
sind alles drei farben die man auf jeden
fall benutzen sie sind beim letzten
angekommen was es in der 24 drin und da
passt jetzt mein ganzes shopping make-up
rein
also setzt sich eine größe mit der ich
arbeiten kann aber sind also müssen hier
aber auf jeden fall nochmal unseren look
fertig machen
[Musik]
also das ist mein neuer look was man
sieht immer noch so aus sagt er
wir wissen zwar schon wieder das fazit
ausfallen würde aber trotzdem sag ich
mal
ich finde den gar nicht mal so schlecht
diesen adventskalender werden jetzt
keine youtube kaufen wie sonst sich
produkte von sonst woher holen oder die
auch schon vielleicht alle produkte zu
hause haben aber gerade für so mädels
oder sagen wir mal was einem arm die so
ein bisschen schminke hat weil sie sich
mal was bei dm geholt hat aber noch
nicht so wirklich auswahl hat dann ist
diese adventskalender hammer ohne hier
schamlos werbung dafür zu machen von
denen wirklich cool
und wenn man ein shopping queen fan ist
dann sowieso dann wird man halt nicht so
blöd enttäuschendes was ich meine
aber ich bin begeistert das war und für
die leute die sich beschweren das
geradezu bilanz kalender unboxing sind
es geht nur noch so ungefähr eine woche
so weiter dann ist es wieder vorbei
und für alle die sich darüber freuen und
vielleicht des ganzen videos anklicken
kam sah mir da freu mich sehr alter
dieser pony beauty wahn
bis zum nächsten mal und jetzt schaue
ich erstmal die neue folge shopping
queens sind viel aber
[Musik]